let's get the view of labor now I'm
joined here in the studio by Shadow
climate change secretary Ed miliband
very good morning to you it's good to
meet you with you
um so quasi quite the chancellor is
coming back from Washington from the IMF
meetings early what do you read into
that this is a government in meltdown
and an economic policy in tatters and
frankly I think the conservative party
should be hanging its head in shame what
that is putting the country through this
is about people's livelihoods people's
homes people's mortgages and you have a
government and let's be clear about why
this has happened you have a government
that embarked on a strategy of saying
let's have massive tax cuts for the
richest in society for big corporations
so-called trickle-down economics which
isn't going to work and also they're
trashing the Economic Institutions of
the country like the office of budget
responsibility that is why the markets
have reacted as they have that is why
there's been such a loss of confidence
in the government and the government's
economic policy and that's why the
budget has got to be ripped up well as
far as quasi question is concerned Greg
Hans who was in this studio in that seat
just a short while ago says It's Not
Unusual to to cut short trips to to the
IMF meetings and the main meetings had
already taken place
you know I think people will be furious
that the government is taking people for
fools you know let's I saw Greg hans's
interview and he says that somehow that
this is a global phenomenon it is not a
global phenomenon there's no other
Finance Minister who's rushing back on
an airplane early from the IMF meetings
there's no other country where central
bank said to have an emergency buying
spree there's no other country where a
government's economic policy is falling
apart at the seams you know this is this
is a collective meltdown on the part of
the government and uh you know the
British people deserve so much better
than what this government is putting the
country through you say you want to see
the mini budget ripped up what elements
do you want to see reversed first of all
the corporation tax cut or the refusal
to go ahead with the rise which was
baked in let's be clear that's 18
billion pounds of unfunded tax cuts
there were other measures like the stamp
Duty cut like the abolishing vat for
foreign visitors here all kinds of
unfunded tax cuts in that category we
also need a proper windfall tax to help
fund the package and crucially this is
this is the two other really important
things we can't have a situation where
the independent office of budget
responsibility is locked in a Cupboard
because that's part of what led to the
problems we've seen you know they were
they were they were basically gagged by
the government and then crucially also
we need an economic strategy that is
credible in terms of growth you see the
government isn't wrong to say it wants
to see more growth and that they've
failed over 12 years they have failed
over 12 years to bring growth but we're
not going to get growth if we believe in
some extreme Fringe theory that cutting
taxes for the ultra wealthy is going to
produce growth we need to actually
invest in the country like in the green
economy of the future which is what a
labor government would do you say scrap
the mini budget and yet you support
elements of it don't you you support the
reversal of the National Insurance rise
the cut in the basic rate of income tax
all measures in the menu well we learn
led the way in saying that the
government shouldn't be raising National
Insurance on ordinary families and we've
said we're not going to reverse if we
were in government and the basic rate
cut which was already programmed in is
in place we weren't going to reverse it
but that's because but that's because we
that's because we're not in favor of
raising taxes on ordinary people but
more than a half more than a half of the
measures uh in the mini budget were
measures we opposed we also said there
should be a proper windfall tax to help
pay for the energy price uh measures
that were taken and then it goes to this
other point which is what is your
economic strategy is there a credible
economic strategy do you are you
trashing the institutions of the country
or are you upholding them but you say
you want the mini budget scrapped and
yet you back key elements of it you
can't have it both ways well no what
we're saying is that we wouldn't reverse
the basic rate you know the question we
would face if we came into government if
the basic rate cut is in place or and
the National Insurance
um the reverse of the National Insurance
rise is would we raise taxes on ordinary
families on twelve and a half thousand
pounds a year well we're not going to do
that
um but let's be clear this is the
government that came forward with its
strategy it's got to go back to a blank
slate start again and come up with a
credible plan a credible plan with
fiscal numbers that add up do you have
fiscal numbers that add up we haven't
really seen Labor's costs well proposals
well no that's not absolutely not true
we we cost we set out the the costings
for everything we propose you know we've
said for example that we would have more
doc nurses and doctors and we've shown
how getting rid of the so-called non-dom
status which allows foreign citizens to
be here and not pay their taxes that
could raise about three billion pounds
we've shown how we can invest in
education by getting rid of the vat
relief on private school for yourself
absolutely everything we we set out
everything we propose is fully funded
and that is the difference labor is the
responsible part in British policies you
know I was I was here a few weeks ago
saying that the the conservatives were
being fiscally irresponsible by having
an energy price price guarantee energy
price package which was only funded by
borrowing not a windfall tax because
there was surprising Labor's taking
notorious for fiscal irresponsibility
and then we saw that added to in the
budget that quasi-karting produced on
the subject of energy which obviously is
your brain you're talking about fracking
today you've been very critical of the
government's plan to lift the ban on
fracking so what are you going to do
about it well we are going to do
everything we can through the House of
Commons and there is support across the
House of Commons for for carrying on
with the ban on fracking uh to try and
force the government to change its mind
why is fracking not the answer first of
all it will make no difference to gas
prices because where the gas is produced
here or produced internationally we pay
the same price for it secondly the
government gave a categorical Assurance
in their Manifesto they said we are not
going to restart fracking unless it can
be categorically shown to be safe and
and they haven't got the evidence and
they're and they're breaking since then
Russia has invaded Ukraine that's had a
massive impact on Energy prices and they
say that it's in the National interest
to reintroduce them more extreme Fringe
views from a government that is of the
extreme Fringe of the conservative party
look Boris Johnson opposed fracking
quasi quatting themselves it a few
months ago fracking will make no
difference to Energy prices much better
stop it well much better to go ahead
with Labor's plans for a clean energy
Sprint for zero carbon power system by
2030. for example the government is also
talking about blocking solar energy the
equivalent of 10 nuclear power stations
worth of solar energy that's completely
wrong solar energy is the cheapest form
of power that we have how do we stop it
we'll do everything we can to work with
MPS from across parties conservative MPS
I'm talking to some conservative MPS we
I will do everything we can to try and
stop this how many Tory MPS are prepared
to go against the government well I I
don't know the answer to that but I know
there is a lot of disquiet from talking
to conservative MPS about this we'll we
will find a way of testing opinion in
the House of Commons you know we get
opposition days and we're thinking about
how we can use at that time uh to have
uh votes on fracking but we do want to
stop this and you know the other thing
is uh and and you know it's so clear
clear to me that people in the country
don't want fracking it's the least
popular form of energy that they that
they can be but the government says
they'll only go ahead if they have local
concerns well they don't quite say that
Liz trusted that during her leadership
campaign that they haven't they she
cannot say what local consent even means
and there is a fear that they can
actually bypass local people when it
comes to fracking that will be quite
wrong and on the subject of of sonar
Farms this trust did say she'd block
them on agricultural land during her
leadership campaign but her argument
would be wouldn't it that they we need
to boost food production at a time when
food prices are soaring and we can't
afford to import them and the biggest
threat to food security is the climate
crisis and you know how much because
listro has sort of made much of this
fact that solar Farms apparently
destroying all that Farmland do you know
how much Farmland is actually being used
by solar panels at the moment 0.1
percent one one thousandth of of uh
farmland and even if we increase solar
panels by five times it would be only
half a percent of Farmland I'm afraid
it's you see there is a piece of this
with with what we saw in the budget
we've got a party that has got dangerous
extreme views essentially taken over the
conservative party and is now trying to
impose those views on the country and it
is bad for the country it's the wrong
priorities for Britain I asked this
question to Greg hands do you expect um
to be in office in a month's time I have
absolutely no idea but you know what if
the conservative party seems really
worried about the trashing of the
conservative party I'm worried about the
trashing of the country I'm worried
about people's mortgages I'm worried
about the the spectacle the the impact
this is having on people across Britain
and I honestly believe that the whole of
the conservative party Bears
responsibility for this they elected Liz
truss they they impose yet another prime
minister uh on us you know I feel like
they're gambles at the casino they bet
the house on one prime minister then
they get rid of them and they bet the
house on another prime minister there's
only one answer for this which is the
conservative budget get out of the way
and let a labor government govern the
country okay Ed mediban thanks very much
thank you